c'est à la maison de famille des eaux
vives à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse que
nous rencontrons un homme aussi
souriante qu'accueillant doyen d'île de
france mais également vice doyen de
france michel chevallier a fêté cet été
ses 110 ans un événement à la hauteur de
son enthousiasme
une haie d'honneur avec d'amélie quai de
l'yser blast où tu es tu these julien
des infirmières et c'était été
formidable je ne vais pas dire ça mais
je me considère comme la bielle et b
j'ai chargé pas d'ennemis et beaucoup
impatients modèles toujours prêt à aider
le personnel de la maison tout en
participant à plusieurs activités tout
particulièrement l'écriture
non monsieur chevalier est arrivé il ya
maintenant quatre ans dans notre maison
il avait donc 106 ans il est très actif
dans l'établissement il a il a vite
trouvé ses repères et il a écrit un
livre avec notre art thérapeute
un livre qui reprend toute son enfance
il n'avait jamais écrit un livre de sa
vie
ce projet l'ami aussi sous la lumière
des projecteurs il a été reçu en mairie
il a vendu une centaine d'olive un récit
retraçant la vie d'un homme sur tout un
siècle dans lequel michel nous raconte
ses nombreuses expériences
après la mort de ma femme et j'ai changé
je dis fructueux faut que tu fasses
quelque chose que je partais au val en
2004 en 2004 michel mis à danser
j'ai lancé par 60 ans et c'était bien
exempt si bien et j'en ai tellement bien
que d'aujourd'hui deux foyers u17 coupe
on est oubliée la paix des pompiers a vu
lindsay c'est un monsieur qui qui a qui
n'a aucune difficulté au niveau cognitif
ni au niveau physique puisqu'il se
déplace très bien avec son déambulateur
un personnage unique et attachant
bientôt arrière arrière grand père qui
se résument lui-même mieux que quiconque
y en a pas beaucoup qui s'appelle comme
moi j'ai pas grise ou quoi